well kirsten and there are concerns  about the possibility of nationwide  protests when the verdict comes down  sheriff joe lombardo joined us this  morning to talk about how metro is  preparing to handle protests  here locally in traditional police work  we prepare  for the inevitable and you know we uh  we over commit and then hopefully you  can just  de-escalate if it doesn't turn out the  way  is is expected um in this case there  could be a plethora  of happenings or decisions you know  acquittal  an indictment dismissal  you know even if there is an indictment  people may not be happy with the  level of indictments well sheriff  lombardo added that metro meets  proactively with members of the  community to talk about controversial  issues  he says community engagement is key when  dealing with these types of situations